sometimes at moments of particular
stress one adult will turn to another
and say stop behaving like a child or
even act your age
this isn't merely rude though it might
be that too it seems that in contact
with given challenges we can revert back
quite quickly to an earlier stage in our
development we leave behind all of our
adult faculties the ones associated with
reason logic calm strength and
perspective and slip very quickly into a
childlike Spectrum marked by Panic rage
despair Terror and appeasement
the specific occasions that shift us
from adult to child are an individual
guide to our traumas
the reason why we behave like a child is
that traumas selectively arrest
emotional development a part of us is
going to remain fixed at whatever age we
become traumatized at so though we may
be 28 or 72 we will to all intents in
contact with a certain kind of
inflammatory situation resemble the
frightened bewildered and ashamed three
or five-year-olds we once were though of
course will be unlikely ever to notice
this Nobel goes off in the mind to
Signal you're now shifting from being 32
to being two the transition happens in a
Flash and it's the work of years of
therapy and self-exploration to be able
to notice the shift and take measures to
soften the damage
to guess at our original traumas we need
only to study triggering situations and
then generalize outwards from them let's
imagine that we get very worked up about
a difficulty at passport control with a
Stern officer or about a dispute with a
neighbor who's threatening legal action
because a tree we planted is blocking
their View
when we Erase Away the local details we
may be able to see an elemental
structure and can then ask ourselves
questions accordingly a powerful man is
adopting a bullying manner towards us
this remind us of anything in the past
or we're suddenly being accused of
having done something bad that we had no
idea about and the repercussions feel
severe does this sound in any way
familiar
memories tend to emerge that Stern
passport officer might map with Eerie
Precision onto an extremely frightening
father or a legal dispute might in its
psychological fundamentals hint at some
awful bullying once suffered at school
when there is a certain kind of Crisis
we should notice how fast we can fall
through the flaws of adulthood 10 or 20
or 40 years slash stories below the
present to the childlike basement of the
Mind a part of us needs to hold the
other steady see the hole blown in our
minds by a triggering event and then
ensure that we can step carefully around
the Gap and take a seat somewhere very
safe on the edge of the room while we
wait for reason to repair the damage
we're so afraid of patronizing ourselves
we can find it very hard to accept the
bewildering way in which in certain
areas at times we truly can be slammed
back into being a frightened panicky
perspectiveless younger version of
ourselves
flaws in our minds may be prone to
collapse at moments of stress but
knowing the danger is more than halfway
to a solution and greater and deserve it
calm